how are you doing sir
hey brother how are you i'm doing
excellent um let me start by saying i've
seen the first nine episodes of season
five
the season is is spectacular i can't say
enough positive things
so happy to hear that man so happy today
it's so good um i i just
i mean it's anyway i could keep going on
for eight minutes just raving about the
season but
what i want to jump in i think that for
fans of your character
they are going to pardon my language
[ __ ] love it
because it is it totally pulls back the
curtain
on who he is and baltimore and it really
explores a lot
can you sort of talk about um what you
know season five and and
what's going to happen whatever you can
say yeah absolutely and i think uh
i'm so excited to hear you say that
because you know you talk about
the fans and the relationship that we
have with fans um
the connection relationship that we have
with these fans of the expanse is unlike
anything that we
have ever had before and so with um
and you know we we've had this
relationship in this constant dialogue
as we're creating this show
and so going into season five i knew
that this was the season that really
dives into amos's past
and it was the one thing that i that i
was really excited to go to and before
the season five
we all had butterflies i felt more
motivated in season five than we did
even back in season one and we all and
we knew how important it was to the show
because it's really
the apex of of our arcs that started
back in season one uh
and then going in in all the work that
i've done and i had the benefit of the
churn i had the benefit of
um ty and daniel to really dive in
amos's backstory and so
every you know every season i would go
back and
create all this in my imagination to be
able to go into season five and
everything that i was seeing in my head
baltimore and my relationship with eric
and everything
uh peaches and and all the experiences
and actually see it and be able to to
work within that it was it was
enormously
creatively satisfying well one of the
other things about season five is
um and and i think that the fans might
not be ready for it is the
it's there's a lot of location work and
it's not on a sound stage
and it feels very like just feels bigger
can you sort of talk about that yeah i
mean i felt like
you know in some ways i feel like i was
in a different movie i remember
showing up uh my first day of shooting
it was i was
in downtown baltimore i didn't have my
the cove
amos's coveralls that i usually wear i
didn't have the rossi crew around me i
wasn't on a set i wasn't on a sound
stage i was in the middle of a city
with over uh you know 500 extras
um and it was bigger in scale and bigger
than anything i've seen before and it
was it kind of
it took me a second to get grounded to
really um you know
understand what story i was telling
yeah i think that uh all that stuff do
you feel like season five almost and i
don't know what the actual num like i
don't know the real
stuff but do you feel like they almost
spent more money on season five
because it feels bigger to me yeah i
mean that's a question
for somebody else but it definitely it
felt a way bigger
to me too i mean uh and i wat you know
we've been watching him
to prepare for this after show thing
that we're doing and uh
i mean i'm i'm blown away at the the
visual effects and the
size and the scale and the i just i'm
i think it's hands down on all levels
the best thing we've ever done
yeah i i really again i think people are
watching are like steve stop
we get it you like the season um what do
you think
would surprise people who are fans of
the series
about what goes on behind the scenes to
bring it to life
if anything
um probably the shirt the amount of
practical sets that we actually use um
you know some sci-fi shows are movies
they're really heavy on visual effects
and green screen
um but there's but you know the expanse
uses
massive massive sets and the details and
the artistry that goes into the
every panel is live and operating on the
oxygen levels and
you know the in and the amount that they
put into it
you you uh if you in season or in
episode four when we get to the top and
we see the damage
you know of the you know we don't want
to say anything but yeah yeah i'm trying
not to say but
but that was all that's you know
like a football field sized warehouse
where they created all that
yeah we're literally walking through the
wreckage so the
the size and scale and the actual
practical sets that we use
i think would just really blow flan fans
away
and uh real quickly something that we
did on
this show that or this season that we've
never done you know
anything like this is brett eisner was
directing an episode and he told me you
know
what we're gonna do is we're gonna have
a helicopter fly over the water
it's gonna uh the camera is gonna pass
over to the crane
the crane is gonna lower the camera down
the dp is gonna catch it as you're
walking
and i thought he was kidding and then
when i showed up he was on the
walkie-talkie talking to the helicopter
and i was like
how far is it going to go with this joke
jesus christ and a helicopter flew over
the wall
do you remember the shot i'm talking
about when you get there helicopter
flies over the water hands the camera to
a crane the crane lowers the
camera on a wire and it catches me the
whole time zeroing in on me as i'm
walking through 100 extras
yeah i know it's it's bonkers uh but
that's another example of season five
uh before i run out of time with you i
definitely have to talk about season six
for a second because
while i am incredibly bummed that season
six is going to be the final season
i'm also so thankful to amazon for
saving the series
and for allowing you guys to end it uh
the way you know
knowing that the end is coming can you
sort of talk about like
both you know being thankful for
everything that's happened but also
you know what it means to you know
knowing that the end is sort of coming
uh you
well okay so i'll start with this i'm
extremely thankful that
you know i i can't believe we made it
this far i can't believe
and also not only we made it this far
the show is healthier and more
successful than ever and we're in season
five you know it just blows my mind
and the fact that we got season six is
such a vote of confidence and we feel so
thankful going to amazon
but in saying that this show has
accomplished a lot of remarkable things
you know
uh about uh you know when we there was a
moment we didn't know we're going
forward and then amazon came in and
saved the day and then now we're at this
point
we are now and and they said that uh
you know i
i uh i can hear you being very careful
with what you want to say i'm being very
careful but all i'm saying is
is who knows what's going to happen
after season six
got it i understand i listen i i i know
i got a rap but i was gonna
yeah and i'll say this this is uh
the fans will not be disappointed and
this is uh this is a
a place of celebration this isn't this
isn't said and
you know so uh that's that's all i'll
say about it